a market building smolders in chernohev
russia insists it's scaling back its
offensive in this part of ukraine but
clearly not here
the town's governor scorned moscow's
claims
yesterday russians have publicly stated
that they are decreasing their offensive
activity towards chernhiv and the kiev
directions do we believe this of course
not all night long they were shelling
chernohiv
the same point made by kiev's mayor and
boxing champion vitani klitschko to eu
officials we received uh
uh yesterday information right now the
russian forces move
uh away from kiev it's not true all
night we listen to sirens this means the
wreckage attack and we listen the huge
explosion uh east of kiev and north of
kiev his means battles there
to the east in hakeef ukrainians claim
russians are now on the back foot
russian forces have failed to dislodge
the defenders of ukraine's second
biggest city in weeks of fierce fighting
and have now been routed from this
village on its outskirts
guys i can say that we are pushing them
back slowly but steadily
i think their morale has dropped
most of them already understood that
they made a huge mistake when they came
here
therefore i think they have no chance
here we will win
yet more evidence of war crimes
committed by russia in donetsk a direct
hit on a civilian residential building
and more satellite pictures of the
devastated city of mariopol before and
after russia's savage bombardment
in peace talks there's been some
progress with russians welcoming what
they see as a key concession by ukraine
ukraine has declared its readiness to
fulfill those fundamental requirements
that russia has been insisting on over
the past few years if these obligations
are fulfilled then the threat of
creating a nato bridgehead on ukrainian
territory will be removed
however work continues negotiations
continue i want to emphasize separately
that the principal position of our
country regarding crimea and donbass
remains unchanged
russia has released more propaganda
pictures and a scanned a ballistic
missile being launched
and footage it says showing ukrainian
air defenses destroyed reduced to
twisted metal
the fear is russia is using the peace
talks and its own claims it's reducing
attacks as cover to let it rally and
regroup for a renewed offensive
dominic waghorn sky news level